the woman who delivered a powerful
statement about her sexual assault by a
Stanford student and gave voice to
survivors nationwide is now coming
forward previously known only as Emily
doe Chanel Miller is sharing her story
with 60 minutes correspondent Bill
Whitaker she's written a memoir set to
be published later this month
it expands on her victim impact
statement that was viewed 11 million
times in just four days after it was
posted online many who shared the letter
said her words inspired them to come
forward with their own stories you
cannot give me back the life I had three
years after her words became a national
rallying cry for survivors of sexual
assault
Janelle Miller is showing her face for
the first time 60 minutes recorded her
reading her 12th page impact statement
where she spoke of the importance of
reclaiming her life I had to force
myself to relearn my real name my
identity to relearn that this is not all
that I am Miller first read these words
back in 2016 at a sentencing hearing for
her assailant Brock Turner he was found
guilty of three counts of felony sexual
assault
Turner attacked Miller behind a dumpster
at a college frat party while she was
passed out two good Samaritans
intervened in newspapers my name was
unconscious intoxicated woman ten
syllables and nothing more than that
many were angered after Judge Aaron
Persky sentenced Turner to just six
months in county jail when he could have
faced up to 14 years behind bars
millions read Miller's powerful words
about her assault it was a pivotal
moment it focused our attention not only
on the devastation of sexual violence
but on the difficulties of pursuing a
case through the criminal justice system
her statement also led California to
pass minimum sentencing requirements for
sexual assault cases and last year
voters recalled Persky
the first such action in more than 80
years she gave voice to the feelings of
shame
an isolation that so many survivors of
sexual violence experienced now speaking
with her name is is one further step
toward her healing yeah you know in that
original impact statement she said that
that judge lit a tiny fire inside of her
because she wanted other people to feel
empowered you can tell that statement
and the way she has taken ownership of
this idea of I will control the
narrative I will speak for my name
exactly well you can see Bill Whitaker's
full interview with Chanel Miller Sunday
September 22nd on 60 minutes then Miller
will join us here on CBS this morning on
September 24th the same day her book no
my name will be released